do we know when that Train's expected to
arrive and what happens when it does
arrive to the city just across from us
here's Fox yesterday uh showing us a bit
more about what's happening at our
border this compared to the group that
you're seeing here as a steady stream of
migrants continued to head to Eagle Pass
this train was seen leaving Central
Mexico yesterday and is expected to
arrive in the city across from me this
week I want to bring in Lieutenant Chris
olz you brought us along last night we
saw that video of the train there do we
know when that train is expected to
arrive and what happens when it does
arrive to the city just across from us
well typically is what we see when we
see these type of Caravans the method of
transportation is usually trains so once
they make it to the northern part of
Mexico they'll get broken up into
smaller groups and then we'll see them
cross between the ports of Entry now we
do expect the train to arrive very soon
but of course we've been seeing a
constant flow here in Eagle Pass with
illegal immigrants Crossing between
ports of entry and when we talk about
the Goda ways you talk about the sheer
number of people that are crossing well
the the the taxpayer the communities
here in Eagle Pass are having to
shoulder that burden and it's our
responsibility as a state to try to
prevent some of these legal Crossings
but as long as the federal government
continues to incentivize illegal
immigration we're going to continue
seeing this flow of illegal immigration
between ports of entry and also these
trains and curand making their way to
the Border Stuart we have new numbers a
new report from the US House committee
on homeland security majority they say
the price tag per year is
$451
billion that is both for the housing and
care of the Asylum Seekers as well as
those known Goda ways did you catch that
did you notice what was on that guy's
shoulder on his uniform there State
Police he's not supposed to be worrying
about the border the federal government
is supposed to be worrying about the
Border when Ronda santis says we're
going to send the Army down to the
border that sounds pretty freaking good
to me even Fox by the way Fox which is
actually covering this stuff right
they're not going to cover this on MSNBC
they're not going to cover it on CNN but
the way they casually cover it like oh
and there's a train going and there's a
whole bunch of people on that train and
they're on their way to the border and
it's just like like these things are
just supposed to happen a country is
supposed to be invaded and look at all
of these nice people and then of course
it always ends up for some Bizarro
reason all of the people fleeing the
oppression always appear to be sort of
well-fed decently dressed men in their
20s to 40s I don't know where all the
chicks are I don't know where all the
tired and the poor and the huddled
masses are where it's old grandma with
one suitcase here's what's going on in
the East Village of New York City this
is literally yesterday illegal
immigrants online to get some of your
stuff
a
d not one
chick that's weird not one old person
not one baby not one kid it's just all
dudes who kind of look like I don't know
maybe Hamas fighter age do we have any
freaking idea who is entering this
country and how stupid do you have to be
that sounds it's going to sound a little
harsh for me to say that sentence this
way if you still live in New York City
and you're seeing that in your
neighborhood East Village used to be
cool and hip and like funky and that's
where comedy standup comedy in America
was born and it's and like music and Bob
Dylan Like It was just such a great
interesting area the Lower East Side and
now it's like being overrun and and if
you live there and you are still
allowing them to take your dollars to do
that like at some point the rubber hits
the road and then you just kind of
deserve what you get and and what you're
going to get is not going to be good I
hate to tell
you